in tonight's powerpanel Fox News
contributor Richard Fowler from The Wall
Street Journal Fox News contributor
Jason Riley and the former deputy
assistant to President George W Bush
Brad Blakeman gentlemen welcome to all
of you good to be here all right Brad I
want to start with you because you were
in the middle of these recounts in 2000
you know what this is like and now we
have multiple states where this is
happening to Leland's point there the
abrams campaign manager in georgia said
this they've been preparing for all
possibilities voters who previously
elected to vote by mail are receiving by
mail today an absentee ballot
application for the December 4th runoff
and we just approved a $250,000 TV buy
they are not conceding Brad they're not
but the math just doesn't work in
Georgia and it's putting in my opinion
good money after bad they shouldn't be
putting that kind of investment out and
putting that false hope out to their
supporters they should be conceding now
there is something to be said about the
Florida races as well as the Arizona
races those are clearly not over until
every vote is counted there the math is
is there their warrant the kind of
recount that is mandatory but certainly
not Georgia
all right so Richard by tomorrow at 5:00
p.m. excuse me by Tuesday 5:00 p.m. and
in Georgia all the counties are supposed
to certify its let's go to the state and
this is supposed to be over I would
imagine there's gonna be legal action in
Georgia because I don't know how they
resolve this with the two sides to and
trends so entrenched at this point yeah
I definitely this will end up at the
course and I'm glad you brought that up
and I'm glad brought Brad brought that
up the ideal of a recon and ideal of
what how long it takes to actually count
votes right I mean I think what people
assume as an election night when we when
networks make projections on that those
are actual winners and that's not
necessarily true they're called
projections for a reason we have to wait
for these individual counties in the
Secretary of State in every state of the
Union to actually certify the election
that takes three four five sometimes
seven days to get done because you have
to count absentee ballots from the
military you have to come absentee
ballot some diplomats absentee ballots
of citizens abroad provisional ballots
and that takes some time so instead of
us rushing this process which I've seen
a lot of folks push us to do including
the president why don't you let these
votes just get counted that is what
democracy is about eight counting votes
it takes
and now listen a lot of people are
wondering what's going on in Arizona
every state is allowed to run these
things within certain parameters the way
that they want to I mean they all have
different you know state statutes and
that kind of thing
in Arizona the fact that it's taking lot
is so long really not that unusual
The Washington Post writes about this
and says state law requires the envelope
these day know because so many people
vote by mail in Arizona the envelope to
be sealed inside and for elections
officials to match each signature to the
one on file with the voters registration
before even opening the envelope in this
election that's about 1.7 million
individual signatures that had to be
confirmed one by one total of about 2.3
million votes were cast in Arizona and
Jason the new totals tonight continued
to tech cinéma up the Democratic
challenger there any path you see for
McSally at this point the Republican
it's it's looking tough for the
Republicans out in Arizona but I don't
think the there's as much suspicion
about the process going on out there is
there is backe strictly down in Florida
I mean we know that some Democrats have
trouble accepting that they've lost
elections we saw this in 2016 it looks
like it's continued earlier this week
but I think the Republicans particularly
in South Florida in Broward County have
reason to be suspicious the election
supervisor there has been repeatedly
reprimanded by judges for destroying
ballots illegally counting bail other
ballots in secret and the real question
is whether the Democrats that are going
in going down there right now are there
because of valid integrity or there to
change the outcome of the election and I
and I think that Republicans are right
to be skeptical the process now I want
to make sure that we've spent some time
on Florida and get all of you to weigh
in on this so I will ask you to move a
little bit briskly Brad I want to start
with you
mark liest who is the attorney who
represents a number of Democrats in the
in is a household name to a lot of
people in these races and in these
fights in court he says this breaking as
provisional ballots are counted and
counties canvass the margin in Florida
Senate race has fallen under 15,000 I
expect the margin to tighten further in
advance of tomorrow's noon deadline and
as I said before this is a jump ball
going into the recount Brad which could
be triggered as soon as 3 o'clock
tomorrow it could but
there's something very suspicious than
in 67 counties in Florida whenever
there's a problem it always comes down
to the Democratic strongholds of Broward
and Palm Beach County I witnessed it
firsthand the governor had to bring a
lawsuit in order to get his people in
there to over to conduct some oversight
we had to do the same thing in the
Florida recount in 2000 there were
ballots found in 2000 trunks of cars and
in in hallways and and the ballot
security was it was non-existent so the
integrity is a question here because
they brought up integrity on Brad
because the FDLE the Florida Department
of Law Enforcement for the lawn for
somebody for the state of Florida has
already looked into this and said they
see no evidence of guys just so people
know there have been two rulings today
that seem to benefit the Scott campaign
at this point because there is you there
are state statutes here in play and
reporting and transparency are that you
know that needs to be now Jason Jason I
want to give you a final word in here
too because bill scher an attorney who's
dealt with a number of these problems in
Broward County says he's been filing
lawsuits against Brenda Snipes ever
since she was appointed for voting
irregularities in Broward County
Brenda Snipes in her election apparatus
caused everybody to have doubts about
where these votes are how many are left
and Jason that's not fair to the left or
the right Republicans or Democrats or
anybody else who voted right now there
there are problems with this election
supervisor it's a track record of
shenanigans down there and yes everyone
knows that the all the votes should be
counted but we need consistent rules to
make sure all of the votes are counted
the right way and consistently and
fairly on both sides and again
Republicans have reason to be suspicious
Democrats we're gonna run out of time
we're gonna run out of time but listen
we know that there are many other court
orders that have come out tonight that
are going to kick in tomorrow and and
listen we know this is far far from over
but I appreciate Jason's use of the word
shenanigan because it's underutilized in
my opinion Richard Jason at Brad thank
you all very much